موضوع عن جدليا في السودان وحول مكتبه
يزعم من اغلقها انها تفسد اخلاق الطلاب
وتضم مؤلفات ليست في مصلحه الطلاب وهل
لهذا السبب اغلقت جامعه البحر الاحمر بشرق
السودان اغلقت ابوابها بحسب مدير عام
مؤسسه الثقافيه المسؤوله عنها الروائي
مهند الذاب هو من اعلن الخبر واسباب
الاغلاق التي وصفها بالواهيه مشيرا الى ان
اداره الجامعه كانت تترصد لاغلاق المكتبه
كونها لا تتبع لادارتها ورغم هذا الجدل
الذي اثره اغلاق المكتبه بحثنا على صفحات
الجامعه في مواقع التواصل ولم نجد اي بيان
او التعليق على القراءه
[موسيقى]
على كل من القهر ينضم الينا الكاتب
والروايه السوداني مهند رجب الذابي مهند
يسعد صباحك اهلا بك يعني الجامعه تقول
انها اغلقت هذه المكتبه بسبب ان كتبها
تفسد اخلاق الطلاب لذلك لماذا اعتبرتم هذه
الاسباب وهي اولا
صباح الخير
هذا الراي اتى بعد مرور ما يقرب من العام
لقد تم افتتاح المكتبه في 10 يا 10 مارس
العمل الماضي
ومنذ هذا التاريخ تمارس المكتبه نشاطها في
استقبال الطلاب والباحثين عن مكان للدراسه
او مكان
للالتقاء بالاصدقاء او مكان للبحث عن
الكتب همم بعد مرور كل هذا الوقت ياتي
مصدر من الجامعه الى همم ليقول هذا الحديث
الذي بدا بالنسبه لنا في مؤسسه الارتفاع
حيث ان افتتاح المكتبه كان حدث المشهوده
شهد حفلا ضخما وتغطي اعلاميه كبيره
وشاركت حتى اداره الجامعه في الاحتفال
بهذه المكتبه ومراحل تجهيزه
مهند يعني المصدر اكاديمي بجامعه البحر
الاحمر هو طلب عدم الكشف عنهويته قال بانه
70% من العوامل التي ادت لاغلاق المكتبه
هي عوامل داخليه ولا علاقه طلابها بما يتم
نشره الان من مساله كتب بتفسد الاخلاق
طبعا حيث انني دائما ما كنت اجد همم
الترحيب والمؤازره من عمليه شؤون الطلاب
فمثلا دكتور ابو بكر بخيل عميد شؤون
الطلاب وقتها كان من اشد الداعمين لقيام
هذه المكتبه ومن نحن مكان كان مخصص لالعاب
البلياردو همم حيث عملنا على استصلاحه
وصيانته وتجهيزه بالطريقه التي ترونها
امامكم حيث دعمتنا الوكاله الامريكيه
للتنميه »
في همم تحويل هذا المكان همم من قاعه
بلياردو الى مكتبه تحتوي على اكثر من
1,000 كتاب وانشطه الكمبيوتر والتصوير
المستندات والطابعات والمكيفات الهواء
ومبردات الماء والاجلاس وغيره همم كانوا
وجود المكتبه في هذه الجامعه وجودا طيبا
هادئا همم امنت الاداره الجامعيه بهذه
المكتبه وحطتها مكاندا لمده خمس سنوات عبر
عقده مواقع
ثم اتفاجانا خلال الثلاثه الاخيره همم بان
يتم اختيارنا بايقاف العمل عبر مسؤوله
المكتبه في مدينه بورسودان همم حيث اخترنا
عميد عماده شؤون المكتبات بانه اكتشف فجاه
ان هناك مكتبه داخل الجامعاته لا تتبع له
ثم تواصلنا مع الدكتور الامين اوشيك مدير
مكتب مدير الجامعه ثم مكتب مدير الجامعه
ثم الاخوه في عماده شؤون الطلاب من اجل
بحث حل هذه المشكله
وللاسف لم نتوافق معهم في حل واصر هذا
الرجل همم على ان يتم اغلاق المكتبه وما
محدثا مديره المكتبه بان هذه الكتب تفسد
الاخلاق فاقترحنا عليه ان يتم ذكر
العناوين التي يرى بانها همم ليس من
الصالح ان توجد في هذه المكتبه لكنه لا
يعرف شيئا عن العناوين لم يسمي تلك
العناوين لم يتحدث عن العناوين عرضنا عليه
ان نسحب كل الكتب التي من شانها ان تجعله
قلقا او قد يراها غير صالحه لطلاب بالغين
عق في مرحله جامعيه لكن كل هذا لم يحدث
للاسف همم وكل المحاولات لاجل بقاء هذه
المكتبه بعد بالفشل حتى بالامس حين حاولنا
ان نحول مقتنيات المكتبه الى مطار اخر
رفضت اداره الجامعه تماما ان تدعنا نستلم
حاجياتنا من المكتبه والاغراض لننقلها الى
مكان اخر وهذا امر
انت زرت المكتبه المكتبه الجامعه
وتطلعت على كتبها يعني هل بالفعل هذه
الكتب الموجوده تفسد الاخلاق يعني من من
حقه الحكم على صلاح الكتب من انه منها غير
الطلاب تفضل
انتهى انتهى هذا الزمن الذي يتصدر فيه
المحكمون لسنا في الدوله الفاطميه كي يتم
تحديد اذا كان هذا الكتاب من كانه ان يقرا
او لا نحن الان نعيش في في فضاء مفتوح كل
الكتب كل الاشياء متوفر عبر فضائل
الانترنت وغيره لا لا لا يوجد كتب يمكننا
ان نسميها هكذا
وبالاخص عندما يتعلق الامر في الجامعه فقد
راعينا تماما نحن في مؤسسه فانا همم حيث
اننا نقوم بعمل كبير جدا بخصوص هذه
المكتبات حيث عاقبنا عدد كبير من المكتبات
داخل السودان في معسكر كلمه للهجئين في
مدينه نياله في دارفور في كسلا في بورسلان
وغيره ودعمنا عدد كبير جدا من المكتبات
والمراعي في المكتبه وجود جميع المعارف
الانسانيه بالتساوي من كتب الفلسفه الى
كتب التدين الى كتب الصحه النفسيه الى كتب
الروايه والشعر والتاريخ
وما الى اخره من دروب المعرفه
ما خطوره ذلك عندما نتحدث عن مكتبه جامعه
الجامعيه صوره مصغره من المجتمع اذا يحصل
ما حصل في الجامعات يعني شو خليته للشارع
الجامعه
بهذه الحجه هذا يعني اننا عد الى مربع
اكثر ظلاما من سنوات حكم الانقاذ حيث كان
الطريق طوال 30 عاما في حكم الانقاذ هو قد
ادى بشكل مباشر الى اضعاف الانسان في
السودان المعرفيه والى خفض السقف المعرفي
للجميع وتحديدا شرق السودان يعني همم جميع
ولايات شرق السودان تعاني جدا همم من تدني
نسبه التعليم بها وانخفاض مستوى الوعي
فيها حيث عملت في هذا المشروع ان افتتح في
هذه الولايات في كل ولايه مكتبه امنا في
ربيع هذا الوعي تحديدا بعد ما بعد الثوره
السودانيه ومحاربتنا العيد لبناء السودان
جديد على امل همم ان ننتصر بال- بالمعرفه
وننتظر بالمكتبات بالعلوم ولكن هذا الامر
من هذه المكتبه من هذا الشخص المسؤول
تحديدا يعني عدنا الى مرحله فقر الوعي
الخاص باداره الجامعيه
بالسودان الى الوراء
بكل تاكيد هذا ممكن جدا شكرا لك